smartphones are the digital control
centers of modern life always at the
ready they carry nearly all the
information we need for day-to-day life
but these small devices are much more
than phones there are many computers and
they are just as susceptible to viruses
eighteen-year-old Marcel Kotze found
this out the hard way a few months ago
he downloaded a contaminated app which
blocked his phone it was ransomware a
form of digital blackmail as I'm s woman
bicep I was totally shocked completely
surprised the children my phone would be
unblocked if I paid a hundred euros by
paysafecard my hand every day in spam
but he didn't cough up he thought it
might be a scam such scams are becoming
more frequent and phones that run on
android operating systems are most at
risk in 2015 there were over 3 million
types of viruses circulating ransomware
often sends out seemingly official
warnings and notices demanding money IT
security expert and ethical hacker marco
di filippo tells people never to pay up
it may not unblock the device he
believes there's a common misconception
about the security of smartphones
penises he'll be daft many people are
very naive and continue to use the
phones like before without protecting
them or even being aware that there's a
risk concerning the many communication
channels a smartphone a sterling
communications Fernandez from smartphone
the danger is as big as with the normal
computers buying the mind right now
public Wi-Fi zones are especially
dangerous all Marco DiFilippo needs is
some simple software to hack into
someone else's phone and spy on the user
data everyone sits here I agreed on we
selected a Wi-Fi network scanned it and
found a victim up 51 here I can see the
data traffic a cation shown this is an
encrypted connection so I can see the
domains but not the content about mr. in
I've or not it was a typical unencrypted
connection where I can also read the
content and in this case that includes I
pass in tin foil often password meatless
and find a very sensitive information
online banking for instance is usually
encrypted but expert hackers can find
their way through the protective layers
and even read passwords and other
supposedly secure data companies need
secure smartphones christophe Edmond is
CEO of sec you smart which developed
software and hardware to protect phones
used by firms and government agencies
handling secret and sensitive
information its products ensure that
Chancellor Angela Merkel's phone is now
spy proof the film zishan anklet 11
companies are very good at securing
their laptops their standard practices
for that but Alison people are still
naive when it comes to smartphones at
least provide a pathway to attack
companies and get hold of secret
information I'm no spots
yet it's not that difficult to protect a
phone you just need to install an
antivirus app and follow a few basic
rules yeah to mine in Dodge City you
should make sure that all communication
data is encrypted to London and only
download apps from trustworthy sources
Rudy can command you should use the
internet cautiously stay away from
dubious sites yes I think the saloon p1
Searson Jeff it's also very very
important to lock the device expand and
use a code using short code then many
people don't do this at they enough to
burn or through in the end Marcel karate
lost a lot of data and photos because he
had to reprogram his phone the first
thing he did was install an antivirus
app